so if you're like me you've been getting
dozens of emails from different websites
you subscribe to or have an account on
saying we've updated our privacy policy
we are now in compliance with GDP our
standards and the question today is
should the United States implement
European GDP our style standards for our
own privacy laws and my answer is yes on
this one the GDP our European standards
went into effect late last month and
basically it's just stronger privacy
rights and it actually has some teeth
companies can be fined up to four
percent of global revenue for Facebook
that would be like a fine of one point
six billion dollars again four point
four percent still means ninety six
percent is not up to fine but what four
percent of a major companies global
revenue is a lot and the idea here is
sort of blow back a response to the
major privacy scandals that we've seen
including Facebook related to Cambridge
analytical and the Trump 2016 campaign
we've also seen other elements of this
and the idea is number one the system is
very opaque the end user unless they
read through endless legal jargon that
they would probably most people would
probably need a lawyer or at least some
legal education to even understand what
it is that that the privacy policy is
and a policy that is not strict enough
gdpr standards are going to have to be
put in place and companies will be at
risk of being fined Bigley so the
question from the audience is do I want
to see the same thing in the United
States and the answer is yes I do and
the arguments against would be well it's
overly burdensome regulation on these
companies it's not really we don't even
know just because you passed the privacy
law just because you require certain
privacy guidelines doesn't mean that you
actually have the resources will or
intent or capabilities to actually
enforce them so it's very possible that
a lot of the companies that actually
updated their privacy guidelines in to
be in compliance with gdpr are still
going to be able to do mostly whatever
it is they want at very low risk of
actually
being caught because it's listen gun
laws in the United States we have a ton
of gun laws in the United States that
don't actually get enforced does the
existence of the law can the existence
of the lobby be called burdensome if
it's never actually enforced I would
argue not really and it could be much
the same thing here and number two we
actually do need to have more control
over what is happening with our privacy
because you hear from the
anti-regulation right that businesses
have an incentive to police themselves
and to self-regulate because if they
don't it's just so bad for their
business that it'll crush their revenue
doesn't happen right we know that's one
of the oldest and most tired talking
points around business regulation it's
been abundantly clear that privacy
issues have not been regulated strictly
enough in the United States and in the
end the amount of profit that these
companies are generating often at almost
zero tax rate or actually zero tax rate
they're going to be fine and I
completely am in favor of something like
this yeah it makes me reflect on what
data of mine I'm comfortable with
companies knowing about you know like
you know say my relationship status may
be a little bit more weary about
companies knowing of that wheree where--
where-- yes weary not tired of query uh
but you know maybe that I'm searching
for ballpoint pens or bicycle tires on
Amazon and then I later see an ad for
them want to go to a different website
yeah I'm a little bit more comfortable
with that
you know I think it goes back to that
tired talking point about how it's not
true that just because you're not doing
anything wrong you don't have any reason
to worry
sure you don't necessarily know what
there is to worry about yeah and you
don't want companies to just have free
range here that's never been an
appealing talking point to me the like I
actually do feel that like I I genuinely
go on the internet assuming that
everything I'm doing is potentially
accessible and I'm sort of okay with
that in some way because I don't really
have that much of a choice but I don't
think that that argument is a good one
which is if I don't have anything to
hide what do I care what they see so I
am in favor of a gdpr style
implementation if you're not email me
and tell me why it is that you are
against it I'd be curious to hear from
the audience